[Musik]
ja häufig ist das so dass glauben ja
immer viele nicht dass die Angehörigen
sich an uns wenden das ist eher in der
Regel so als dass wir uns an die
Angehörigen wenn weil viele Angehöriger
eben auch dann keine Interesse haben und
das ist uns ja auch bewusst manchmal
entsteht der Kontakt auch über die
Polizei weil die natürlich verzweifelt
sind Frank Schneider ist bildchef
Reporter und einer der erfahrenen
Journalisten in Deutschlands größter
polizei-redaktion in dieser
Spezialausgabe von Tatort Deutschland
gibt der Einblicke in seine Arbeit und
die von Ermittlern und Staatsanwälten
und in das Gefühlsleben von Angehörigen
mit denen er immer wieder zu tun hat
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
etwa 5 Millionen Straftaten registrieren
die Behörden jährlichen Deutschland
davon rund 3000 Tötungsdelikte zwischen
250 und 400 davon gelten nach Abschluss
der Ermittlungen als Morde aber wann
schlägt ein Fall hohe Wellen welche
Straftaten berühren uns was sind
Schicksale die man nie vergisst mein
Name ist Sky du Mont und ich begrüße
euch zum Staffelfinale unseres True
Crime Podcasts
in mehr als zwei Jahrzehnten seiner
Arbeit das Reporter haben Frank
Schneiders wacheaugen hinter der dunkel
gerannten Brille schon viele schlimme
Dinge gesehen er ist damals wie heute
immer dicht dran an Tatorten und den
Ermittlern wie hat sich deren Arbeit
über die Jahre entwickelt es hat sich
viel verändert in den aktuellen
Ermittlungen gerade was jetzt
Telekommunikation am betrifft eben
funkzellen-daten aber das hilft
natürlich bei Coldplay es ist nicht weil
die Daten ja alle überhaupt nicht mehr
vorhanden sind bzw es damals noch gar
kein Handys gab das vergisst man ja
häufig heute es gab damals einfach
schlicht keine Handys und vor diesem
Hintergrund hat sich schon einiges
verändert also gerade mantrailerhunde da
gibt es heute viel besser ausgebildete
Hunde die eben auch Spuren und auch nach
Wochen teilweise noch nach Monaten
aufnehmen können es gibt heute viel
bessere Leichenspürhunde die zum
Beispiel auch auf Wasser leichengase
erschnüffeln können die eben an der
Wasseroberfläche austreten minimalst
aber es gibt bestimmt trainierte Hunde
die können das eben feststellen das
heißt gerade wenn eine Leiche fehlt das
muss man ja immer wieder betrachten wenn
in einem Mordfall die Leiche fehlt Finn
und selbst wenn man einen Tag verdicht
ihn hat solange die Leiche fehlt seine
Verurteilung extrem unwahrscheinlich
keine Leiche kein Verbrechen könnte man
das kurz zusammenfassen manchmal gibt es
aber auch nur Teile einer Leiche wie ein
aktueller Fall zeigt der frankschneider
derzeit beschäftigt nicht ganz kurz Case
aber doch nicht ganz gelöst der Fall um
Kai m präsentiert den grausamen Mord an
einem ehemaligen Rocker und Gangmitglied
was ist da los am Anfang wusste man bei
diesem zerstückelten Rocker eigentlich
nur der wurde in Arm im Rhein gefunden
und es war sehr schnell klar dass es ein
Rocker weil der Arm halt total tätowiert
war und es war schnell klar es ist ein
Hells Angel und das war das einzige aber
die Polizei nimmt nicht nur
Fingerabdrücke von Tätern oder nimmt
DNA-Spuren sondern der Mann war
vorbestraft und deshalb wusste man auch
welche Tattoos er hat die werden dann
auch wirklich fotografiert gerade so
diese besonderen Tätowierungen werden
dann erfasst und dadurch wusste man sehr
schnell wo man die Fingerabdrücke noch
gar nicht genommen hatte das ist nämlich
nicht so einfach bei Wasserleichen und
dass diese Arm wurde ja im reinen Wasser
gefunden wusste man Hand der Tätowierung
schon um wen es sich bei diesem Opfer
handelt nämlich um den Hells Angel kaym
die Polizei kennt also das Opfer aber
ein einzelner Arm sagt noch nicht viel
aus das Opfer kann durchaus noch leben
oder es ist eine fingierte wenn auch
sehr grausige bewusst gelegte Spur eine
Fährte um Größeres zu vertuschen die
Ermittler und auch der erfahrene
Reporter stehen vor vielen Fragen der
erstmal war total schwierig man hatte
erst nur den Arm kurz darauf dann aber
auch noch den Torso aber dann hört es
eben auf weitere Leichenteile wurden
nicht gefunden und man konnte anhand der
Leichenteile erstmal gar nicht
feststellen wie ist der ums Leben
gekommen man wusste nur er ist
postmortem wie man das in der
fachspracheen eben nach dem Tod
zerstückelt worden aber wir getötet
wurde das wusste man zu dem damaligen
Zeitpunkt nicht das hat sich erst viel
später geklärt als einen Kronzeuge
auftauchte und dann die Beamten geführt
hat zu den Leichen teilen die noch
fehlten unter anderem den Kopf und in
diesem Kopf wurde dann Projektile
gefunden die Bild-Zeitung in NRW hat
sich intensiv mit diesem Fall aus dem
kriminellen Rockermilieu befasst und
Titel dem Juli 2022 sechs Rocker auf der
Anklagebank und der mutmaßliche Killer
sonnt sich im Ausland es soll sich bei
den Verbrechen um einen Racheakt
gehandelt haben an dem sich neben den
beiden Hauptverdächtigen raminjekt der
parast und Francesco g die Rocker
Leonard g 43 Alfredo f36
alessioc 45 und der spätere Kronzeuge
Ramadani beteiligt haben sollen das
Opfer war laut Anklage in
Mönchengladbach in einem Autoanhänger
erschossen und anschließend zerstückelt
worden die Körperteile wurden erst den
Plastiktüten und dann in speiseölfässer
gepackt danach in Beton gegossen und
später im Rhein sowie im
Rhein-Herne-Kanal versenkt später war
zuerst ein Arm im Rhein und an der Torso
wieder aufgetaucht
aber wie sind die Angeklagten auf die
gerichtsbank gekommen und woher weiß man
überhaupt dass der Hauptverdächtige sich
ins Ausland abgesetzt hat Fragen auf die
wir am Ende dieser Episode noch mal
eingehen werden
[Musik]
zurück zu den ungelösten Fällen bei den
meisten mordverbrechen hat man eine
Leiche man hat Spuren man hat vielleicht
sogar Tatverdächtige Personen und dann
ist es trotzdem nicht möglich einen Fall
aufzuklären Tatort Deutschland
berichtete wie ihr wisst ausführlich
über solche cold cases ja ein cold cases
im Endeffekt wie es eben auch schon
heißt ein kalter Fall der ist deshalb
kalt weil man nicht auf ein Täter
gekommen ist und irgendwann werden die
Ermittlungen dann auch eingestellt weil
man nicht weiterkommt was aber nicht
heißt weil mord verjährt nie das ist
kein Spruch das ist nun mal so die
Ermittlung auch jederzeit wieder
aufgenommen werden können wenn es neue
Hinweise gibt jetzt ist aber bei cold
cases so dass man sich irgendwann
entschieden hat zu sagen nein wir warten
jetzt nicht auf den berühmten neuen
Hinweis auf den neuen Zeugen sondern wir
gehen her nehmen dieser sogenannten
Altfälle und lassen die von jüngeren
Kollegen oder anderen erfahrenen
Kollegen noch mal überprüfen die sollen
sich die Akte einfach noch mal völlig
unvoreingenommen nehmen sollen das noch
mal durchgehen das ist natürlich auch
ganz entscheidend und wichtig mit den
neuen technischen Methoden der
Spurensicherung und Spuren Auswertung
nochmal behandeln weil gerade im Bereich
der DNA-Spur gibt es natürlich heute
viel viel größere Möglichkeiten vor 20
Jahren braucht man ganz im Blutfleck
heute reicht der Teil einer Hautschuppe
für eine DNA und dadurch konnte man
teilweise sicher gestellten asservaten
wie das hier heißt also Kleidungsstücken
oder ähnlichem auch manchmal noch Spuren
des Täters finden die man damals nicht
auswerten konnte man muss nämlich wissen
diese Sachen werden in luftdicht
verschlossenen Plastiktüten verwahrt
also die kann man auch nach 20 30 Jahren
noch aus der Asservatenkammer holen und
kann die neu gerichtsmedizinisch oder
spurentechnisch oder fasertechnisch
untersuchen in Büchern oder Filmen sind
es oft alte Ermittler die sich in
verstaubte Akten stürzen im wahren Leben
spielt das Alter kaum eine Rolle wie
Frank Schneider berichtet bei cold Cases
sind es eben auch häufig sehr junge
Kommissare die unvoreingenommen diese
Akte sich noch mal nehmen sollen einfach
nur mal ganz neu drauf gucken einfach
sagen ich fange noch mal bei Null an ich
kenne den Fall ich gucke mir einfach
noch mal an lass ihn auf mich wirken
lass die ganzen Hinweise die ganzen
Vernehmungen die ganzen Spuren die
gefunden wurden noch mal auf mich wirken
um zu gucken habe ich vielleicht eine
Idee es gibt aber auch gerade
Nordrhein-Westfalen hat man das mit sehr
viel Erfolg wiederbelebt die sogenannten
Rentner Cops nennt man die ein wenig das
sind wirklich pensionierte
Hauptkommissare ehemalige Leiter von
Mordkommission häufig die noch meine
Dienst versetzt wurden die es gab einen
Aufruf des Innenministeriums wer möchte
sich sozusagen noch mal ein zwei Jahre
Dienst verpflichten und noch mal
unterstützen weil die natürlich war ein
unglaublichen Erfahrungsschatz verfügen
und da hat man eben auch gerade diese
Mischung aus alten Super erfahrenen
Ermittlern und Jungen die auch zum Glück
was das neue Technik anbetrifft neue
Auswertungsmöglichkeiten neue
spurensicherungsmöglichkeiten einfach
durchmischt und hat schon die ersten
Erfolge auch wirklich dass man die
ersten Fehler die man wieder aufgenommen
hat und genau diese Verbrechen werden
dann auch irgendwann bei Tatort
Deutschland von den cold cases zu den
gelösten Fällen wechseln ein gutes
Beispiel für einen Code der Ball zu den
gelösten Fällen gehören könnte und er
dabei die ganze Welt bewegt ist der Fall
Maddie McCann
mai 2007 Praia de los an der
portugiesischen Algarve der Ort ist von
Appartementhäusern und Hotels der
mittleren bis gehobenen Preisklasse
geprägt der Tourismus durchdringt alles
die Menschen hier leben gut davon die
Gastronomie des Ortes ist immer besucht
so auch die Bar des apartmentkomplexes
Ocean Club in dem die kleine Maddie
McCann zusammen mit ihren Eltern Kate
und Jared Meghan Ferien macht von einer
Anhöhe aus kann man die Ferienanlage gut
überblicken am Abend des dritten Mal
2007 sitzen madeleins Eltern hier in
dieser Tapas Bar auf der anderen Seite
des Pools beim Abendessen das Apartment
war von der Tapas Bar aus zu sehen man
konnte die Terrasse sehen den Eingang
das ist der vorletzt Abend ihres
Urlaubsziel in Praia da Luzern Portugal
die mir kennen sitzen zusammen mit drei
befreundeten Familien die Erwachsenen
wechseln sich alle halbe Stunde ab und
nach den schlafenden Kindern zu sehen
gegen 22 Uhr ist Mädels Mutter Kate an
der Reihe sie verlässt also die Tapas
Bar läuft am Pool entlang um zu
Appartement 5a des Ocean Club zu
gelangen das hier im Erdgeschoss dieses
Gebäudes liegt um zum Apartment zu
kommen muss die Rezeption und über diese
kleine Straße laufen die Tapas Bar
gehört zu dem Apartmentkomplex ist aber
auch für Gäste von außerhalb geöffnet
daher muss Kate diesen kleinen Umweg
machen der sie aber vielleicht 30
Sekunden kostet das ist nichts
besonderes das machen alle Urlauber hier
genauso
22 Uhr das Zimmer ihrer Tochter betritt
stellen Sie zunächst fest dass sie ein
Windzug entgegen haucht und bemerkt dann
das Madeline nicht mehr in ihrem Bett
nicht
[Musik]
unsere Tatort Deutschland Episode zu
Maddie McCann zeigt den Fall in allen
Einzelheiten seinen Verwirrungen und
Verstrickungen es ist eine Ermittlung
die bis heute anhält die dazu geführt
hat dass der dringend tatverdächtige
Christian B heute in Niedersachsen auf
seinen Prozess wartet am Ende wird
dieser Cold Case zu einem Verbrechen das
geahndet werden konnte und den Opfern
Gerechtigkeit zukommen lässt aber Frank
Schneider kennt dutzende Fälle die ihn
nicht loslassen bei denen er als
Reporter instinktiv spürt dass die
Lösung auf der Hand liegen müsste aber
Beweise und Spuren ihr Geheimnis nicht
preisgeben wir im Fall Heidi Tannhäuser
ja im Fall Pei die dannhäuser ist so ein
bisschen das Problem es gibt den
sogenannten berechtigten Spurenleger so
nennt das die Polizei und zwar ist das
natürlich in dem Fall ein Lebensgefährte
ein Ehepartner einen einen Verwandter
auch ein guter Freund vielleicht der
regelmäßig in dem Haushalt ein und aus
geht das heißt wenn man Spuren von ihm
findet in dem Haus ist gar kein Beweis
weil er ist ja ständig da gewesen
wenn du irgendwo
bist die Ermittler gehen im Fall dann
Häuser relativ schnell von einem
Verbrechen aus und suchen das Opfer die
Ermittlungen bringen hunderte Spuren zu
Tage die führen aber oft nur im Kreis
herum Heidi bleibt bis heute
verschwunden was war passiert und stellt
die Familie und Freunde bis heute vor
ein düsteres Rätsel in der Nacht vom 13
auf den 14 November 2013 verändert sich
für Heidi Tannhäuser alles die
lebenslustige und attraktive
Postangestellte verschwindet spurlos aus
ihrem Haus seitdem gilt sie als vermisst
ihre Schwestern Stefanie prangal und
Petra Prado geben über all die Jahre
nicht auf sie gehen an die
Öffentlichkeit Reporter der Bild-Zeitung
unterstützen die Angehörigen bei ihrer
Suche nach der Wahrheit auch Frank
Schneider hat immer wieder intensiven
Kontakt zu den Opfern und zu den
ermittelnden kriminalbeamtinnen und
Beamten aufgebaut war und ist
Ansprechpartner der Presse und manchmal
sogar ein vertraut
ja das kann sich daraus entwickeln mit
Ermittlern ist natürlich auch ganz ganz
wichtig dass man ein
Vertrauensverhältnis hat wie geht man
miteinander um die müssen natürlich auch
wissen mit Informationen geht man damit
vertraulich umgeht man damit sorgsam um
die größte Gefahr für Ermittler ist
natürlich immer dass man die
Ermittlungen gefährden könnte wenn man
etwas veröffentlicht was zu diesem
Zeitpunkt natürlich für die Polizisten
schwierig wäre bei
Opfern ist es eigentlich so dass sie
eine große Hoffnung auch mit uns
verknüpfen als Reporter weil sie
natürlich Hoffnung haben wenn wir etwas
veröffentlichen es gibt doch noch
endlich den entscheidenden Hinweis ganz
extrem ist das eigentlich immer bei
vermissten fällen weil dann die Leute
immer hoffen vielleicht kann durch eine
neue Veröffentlichung endlich rauskommen
wo ist der geliebte Mensch den ich
vermisse und bei vermissten Fällen ist
eben dieses große Fragezeichen dieses
warum wieso was ist passiert
unerträglich
sehr oft ist das Verschwinden einer
Person wie bei Heidi dannhäuser nicht
gleich ein Grund für die Polizei sofort
alle ermittlungsregister zu ziehen wie
Frank Schneider weiß was es häufig das
Problem dass meistens wenn jemand auf
seinem Lebensraum verschwindet ein
Erwachsener erstmal er verschwinden darf
die Polizei ermitteln nicht sofort wenn
es keine Hinweise gibt auf ein
Verbrechen das heißt derjenige hat auch
natürlich alle Zeit der Welt in seinem
Lebensumfeld in seinem geschlossenen
Räumen diese Spuren auch erstmal zu
verwischen oder zu beseitigen eben auch
wenn man einen Fall gehabt der ist auch
nie am Ende geklärt worden da ist die
Ehefrau eines Polizeibeamten auch
ausgerechnet noch verschwunden die
Leiche ist nie gefunden worden man hat
die blutverschmierten Matratzen gefunden
später das Ehebettes da hat er dann
einfach behauptet der Ehemann hätte die
weggeworfen es war eigentlich alles klar
dass er der Täter sein muss aber die
Beweise haben eben nie ausgereicht für
eine Anklage und das ist nun mal in
unserem Rechtssystem ja auch zum Glück
so im Zweifel für den Angeklagten er
muss nicht seine Unschuld beweisen und
man muss ihn die Tat beweisen und
manchmal fehlt dann eben der endgültige
weiß und häufig ist es eben die Leiche
aber eine Leiche allein löst keinen Fall
es ist auch häufig immer wieder das
Problem mit den Leichen wenn Leichen zum
Beispiel verbrannt sind wenn sie lange
im Wasser gelegen haben dann werden eben
wichtige Spuren vernichtet und teilweise
kann man da nicht mehr genau feststellen
wie sind sie wirklich ums Leben gekommen
dazu kommen wenn man mehrere Täter hat
welcher Täter hat jetzt wirklich das
Opfer getötet
NRW Chefreporter Franz Schneider ist
nach Berlin gekommen um über seine
persönlichen Erfahrungen zu sprechen die
er mit gelösten und ungelösten
Verbrechen gemacht hat die meisten diese
Kriminalfälle haben wir euch in unserer
podcastreihe Tatort Deutschland auch
vorgestellt es gibt aber auch
Geschehnisse an die erinnert sich der
Reporter zurück weil Täter und Opfer den
Ermittlern und der Presse bekannt waren
aber dennoch niemand verurteilt werden
konnte ich kann mich immer noch sehr gut
an einen Fall erinnern der war
dramatisch das war Silvester im
Sauerland da tritt eine maskiert Person
kurz vor Mitternacht man stand schon
draußen vom Haus wartete auf die
silvesterböllerei an ein junges Pärchen
heran schießt Beine in den Kopf und auch
noch einem Zeugen der daneben steht
dieser Zeuge überlebt mit Aron Krach
kann sie aber nicht erinnern dass
Pärchen ist tot und man hat sehr schnell
den Hinweis darauf dass der Ex-Freund
der jungen Frau ist der Sauer ist dass
die neuen Freund hat man führt noch in
der gleichen Nacht eine Razzia durch in
dessen Wohngebäude kann auch ihn dort
antreffen seinen Bruder und noch zwei
weitere Personen
und die Polizei stellt die Jacken sicher
dieser Männer macht aber einen Fehler
sie packen alle Jacken in ein und
dieselbe Tüte und hinter wird
festgestellt ja die Schmauchspuren der
einzelnen Patronen die abgefeuert wurden
sind an einer Jacke aber an einer
anderen Jacke auch und das waren
sogenannte Abriebspuren und deswegen im
Zweifel für den Angeklagten musste am
Ende er freigesprochen werden weil man
nicht genau sagen konnte wer von den
beiden Brüdern hat wirklich geschossen
solche Fälle sind tragisch aber im
stressigen Alltag der Ermittler und
Reporter passieren noch Fehler
gleichzeitig stehen der Polizei wie ganz
am Beginn der Episode erwähnt neue und
verbesserte Ermittlungsmöglichkeiten zur
Verfügung in den meisten aller Fälle
gelingt damit die Lösung der
verbrecherischen Rätsel im als
aussichtslos angenommenen Fall des
spurlos verschwundenen Pia Pahlke hätten
neue Methoden auch fast zum Erfolg
geführt aber leider nur fast ein
tragischer Code Case der deshalb hier
parke ist in vielerlei Hinsicht sehr das
erstmal ist das besonders tragisches
handelt sich um einen behinderten Jungen
der aber trotzdem so ein bisschen ins
Leben gefunden hat in einer
Behindertenwerkstatt lebt dort
eigentlich so ein bisschen ins Leben
zurückgefunden hat und sein eigenes Ding
macht seine kleinen eigenen Räume hat
das war immer so wichtig
Selbstständigkeit allerdings ein
bisschen und dann verschwindet er
einfach auf so einem Weg zum Einkauf er
hat sich gerne einfach nur eine
Getränkedose geholt so SAP irgendwas
ganz tolles er darf selber losgehen und
sich was kaufen und dann verschwindet er
wirklich spurlos auf diesen Parkplatz
keiner beobachtet etwas wie man ins Auto
steigt ihn anspricht das ist schon
extrem ungewöhnlich es gibt sogar keine
Zeugen die Bild-Zeitung greift das Thema
sofort auf sucht nach Zeugen und
schreibt Pierre Spur endete im
Rotlichtmilieu
geistig behindert und 21 Jahre alt
verschwindet am 17 September 2013 in
Essen er verließ sein Zimmer in der
Heimstadt Engelbert gegen 19 Uhr und
verschwindet spurlos nicht ganz spurlos
was Menschen nicht mehr wahrnehmen
können speziell trainierte Hunde in den
meisten Fällen noch problemlos wittern
und so setzt die Polizei NRW alles in
die Fähigkeiten seiner vierbeinigen
Kollegen und dann geht es eben diese
mentrailer Runde die man irgendwann
eingesetzt hat und die führen dann über
die Autobahn bis nach Holland bis nach
Amsterdam bis ins Rotlichtviertel und da
war natürlich die große Sorge der
Ermittler möglicherweise ein so
beeinträchtigter junger Mann der sich
nicht wehren kann denn ich weiß was er
machen soll wir Hilfe holen soll dass
der möglicherweise verschleppt worden
ist ins Rotlichtmilieu der angeboten
wird aber gleichzeitig natürlich auch
die riesengroße Sorge das haben auch die
Eltern die Verwandten immer gesagt wenn
er etwas machen soll was auf gar keinen
Fall machen will dann wird er auch sauer
und heute auch laut und das natürlich
die große Sorge der Ermittler ist der
vielleicht laut geworden Täter wollen
dass er ruhig ist und haben ihn dann
möglicherweise auch getötet erst bis
heute verschwunden und es ist in so
einem Fall natürlich so dass die Polizei
sagt der kann nicht abgetaut sein der
ist ja gar nicht fähig ein eigenes Leben
zu führen also bleibt nun die
Möglichkeit entweder wird irgendwo
gefangen gehalten die Hoffnung der
Eltern ist vielleicht hat er jemanden
gefunden der sich um ihn kümmert und es
vielleicht sogar in seinem Sinne gut mit
ihm meint oder es eben getötet worden
solche extrem talentierten und gut
trainierten Hunde laufen natürlich nicht
die ganze Strecke von hunderten
Kilometern am Stück in Etappen wurden
zum Beispiel die Spur vorm pierre-palke
beginnend am Parkplatz wo der Junge
verschwand erst nur bis zur
Autobahnauffahrt in die vom Hund
angezeigte Fahrtrichtung verfolgt dann
setzen der Hundeführer und sein Kollege
auf Pfoten in ihrem Einsatzfahrzeug um
wie man fachlich richtig sagt
sie fahren also bis zur nächsten Abfahrt
und dann nimmt der Hund wieder Witterung
auf und zeigt die Richtung an für diesen
Prozess der spurenverfolgung sperrten
die Beamten die Autobahn immer wieder in
kleinen Abschnitten ab der Hund und
seine menschlichen Partner in Uniform
sind dann eben immer weitergelaufen und
gefahren bis nach Amsterdam und dort von
der Autobahnabfahrt bis in das
Rotlichtviertel da verliert sich dann
zwischen zwei eher schattigen
Etablissements die Spur wo pierpahlke
genau seine Reise beendete das weiß
keiner
[Musik]
die Rolle der Berichterstattung durch
die Presse ist sehr wichtig oft hilft es
die jeweiligen Ermittlungen
voranzutreiben und auch jeder Code Case
der bei Tatort Deutschland als Podcast
publiziert wird birgt für Reporter wie
Frank Schneider jedes Mal die Chance auf
neuen Informationen von den Menschen die
zuhören der häufig ist das so dass
glauben ja immer viele nicht dass die
Angehörigen sich an uns wenden das ist
eher in der Regel so als dass wir uns an
die Angehörigen wenn weil viele
Angehöriger eben auch dann kein
Interesse haben und das ist uns ja auch
bewusst manchmal entsteht der Kontakt
auch über die Polizei weil die natürlich
verzweifelt sind auch hier im Fall der
Familie Schulze in Drage ist es ja so
dass immer noch zwei fehlen und die
Menschen wollen halt Gewissheit auch
hier ist relativ klar die sind beide
nicht mehr im Leben aber man möchte sie
auch beerdigen man möchte trauern möchte
auch verstehen man möchte wissen was ist
passiert Ungewissheit ist das aller
aller schlimmste was es für Angehörige
geben kann und deswegen ist es
Angehörigen häufig auch so wichtig mit
Medien zu sprechen weil sie damit ein
Stück Hoffnung verknüpfen endlich doch
noch geklärt zu bekommen was ist
wirklich passiert
wohl am härtesten trifft das Eltern
deren Kinder verschwinden für die es
noch keine Gewissheit über deren
Verbleib und Schicksal gibt das ist auch
etwas was nicht nur den Chefreporter
Frank Schneider bewegt sondern auch den
privaten Menschen und Vater ja ich muss
sagen es fallen mir direkt mehrere Fälle
ein die mich immer wieder noch
beschäftigen wo ich auch immer wieder
selber gerne irgendwann doch mal wissen
möchte was es wirklich passiert da fällt
mir ein Tanja mühlinghaus aus Wuppertal
da habe ich zum Beispiel mit der Mutter
gesprochen wenige Tage nach dem
Verschwinden die hatte eben auch die
große Hoffnung über Medien
Veröffentlichung doch noch den Hinweis
zu bekommen
der Tag an dem Tanja verschwand da hatte
ich schon so ein komisches Gefühl im
Bauch Tanja das dauert lange bis ich
dich wiedersehe 20 bis 30 Jahre wenn
überhaupt diese Intuition die hatte ich
sofort 1998
tanja mühlinghaus ist ein hübscher
Teenager ein jungen Schwarm wer in der
Bravo stehen könnte und das tat sie
später auch aber leider unter traurigen
Vorzeichen die 15-Jährige geht auf ein
Gymnasium in Wuppertal sie sind
sportliches Mädchen fährt gern Ski und
träumte von eines Tages Tänzerin zu
werden seit einigen Wochen hat die
15-Jährige damals einen festen Freund am
21 oktober 1998 einem Mittwoch soll sie
eigentlich ganz normal zur Schule gehen
aber sie verlässt das Elternhaus und
verschwindet spurlos
Frank Schneider ist Ende der 90er schon
bei der Bild in NRW und berichtete
damals ausführlich über Tanjas
verschwinden
für Tatort Deutschland war er wieder vor
Ort wir sind hier in Wuppertal und hier
verschwand Tanja mühlinghaus damals war
ich jüngereporter und habe diesen Fall
damals schon verfolgt man hört das immer
spurlos verschwinden aber man kann es
sich nicht vorstellen es war helllichter
Tag sie ging zur Bushaltestelle und
plötzlich war sie einfach weg
heute im Gespräch in der Axel springe
verlagszentrale erinnert sich Frank
Schneider noch mal an den Fall der ihn
schon so lange bewegt der Fall ist doch
vielen Ebenen völlig anders als ähnliche
Verbrechen der hat das Mädchen noch
selber zwei Briefe an die Eltern
geschrieben und die Handschrift ist
definitiv von ihr die Eltern sagen
allerdings so hätte die nicht
geschrieben das war nicht ihr Stil die
scheinen diktiert zu sein aber man hat
nie herausgefunden wo sie wirklich hin
ist was ist ihr dann passiert dann
tauchte mal irgendwann ein mysteriöser
Zeuge auf der behauptete sie seien eine
druckerkolonne geraten sei dann
erschossen worden das war aber hinterher
ein Hochstapler der mit dem Schicksal
der Familie gespielt hat also auch noch
ganz tragisch noch mit diesen Menschen
den es eh schon so schlecht geht noch so
umzugehen die Ehe der Eltern ist daran
gescheitert am Ende weil dann auch
Misstrauen noch in der Familie entstand
die Mutter ihren eigenen also die Mutter
den Vater verdächtig hat kann er was
damit zu tun haben also es gab wirklich
viele Ungereimtheiten auch die Polizei
hat viele Dinge nicht verstanden es war
am Ende auch wirklich nie klar hat sie
das Haus überhaupt noch lebend verl auch
in der Tatort Deutschland Episode zum
Fall Tanja mühlinghaus spürt man die
Verzweiflung der Mutter als sie die
Menschen die ihr zuhören und so
vielleicht auch den oder die Täter
anfleht ein Lebenszeichen ihrer Tochter
zu geben und diese Mutter ist nicht die
einzige die einen solchen Horror
durchleben muss aber die Deborah saßen
Debby aus Düsseldorf die hat mich auch
immer wieder beschäftigt auch bis da ist
heute nichts geklärt und auch der Fall
ist so unfassbar tragisch die ältere
Schwester die eigentlich damals Derby
nach Hause bringen sollte von der Schule
hatte das Vergessen ausgleichen auf
diesem Weg verschwindet dann Debby und
die Schwester ist mit diesem sagen wir
mal Druck und diesen Schuldgefühl nicht
klar gekommen die hat sich mehrere Jahre
später umgebracht und das muss man sich
vorstellen Deborah Debbie saßen ist 8
Jahre alt als sie plötzlich verschwindet
das Kind aus Düsseldorf kommt am 13
februar 1996 gerade vom
Schwimmunterricht sie muss aber noch mal
kurz zur Schule zurück weil sie etwas
vergessen hat um 12 Uhr wird Debby dann
ein letztes Mal gesehen die Eltern
melden Sie noch am gleichen Tag als
vermisst die Polizei verfolgt alle
Spuren vergeblich Debbie bleibt
verschwunden das Tragische Verschwinden
des Mädchens ist heute der kälteste
aller cold cases Titel die Bild im Jahr
2021 die Mutter verliert das eine Kind
ist es vermisst es ist weg
wahrscheinlich am Verbrechen zum Opfer
gefallen und die ältere Schwester bringt
sich Jahre später um weil sie das Gefühl
hat sie ist mit schuld weil sie sie
nicht nach Hause gebracht hat also ist
dann trag ich überhaupt nicht zu
überbieten ob Frank Schneider sitzt
nachdenklich in seinem Sessel sein Blick
wird Ernst ich muss immer sagen es gibt
so viele vermisste Kinder jedes Jahr
immer ein paar die nie wieder auftauchen
und wenn wir diese Serientäter sehen wie
damals die Truhen Frankreich als Belgien
die da in den Keller verließen waren
wenn wir sehen den Fall damals in
Österreich mit dem mit dem Keller
verließ wo ein Mädchen über Jahre
gefangen gehalten wurde dann habe ich
manchmal so diese Horrorvorstellung
sitzen da Kinder irgendwo im Kellern
sind gefangen gehalten weil man hätte
sich das früher nie vorstellen können
nachdem die Fehler aber bekannt geworden
sind und auch Natascha Kampusch nach so
vielen Jahren flüchten konnte da ist
einem klar es gibt möglicherweise Dinge
die wollen wir gar nicht wissen und das
ist auch was mich so schockiert da
draußen laufen wahrscheinlich sehr in
Täter rum die ist einfach nur immer
geschafft haben die Taten gut genug zu
vertuschen der Chef Reporter ist sich
sicher dass wir alle dazu beitragen
können dass vielleicht solche Dinge wie
Sie Tanja Maddie Deborah oder Pierre
passiert sind seltener Geschehen er
appelliert an unsere Aufmerksamkeit im
Alltag also eigentlich gibt's nur einen
ganz ganz wichtiges Signal was sie auch
allen sagen möchte wenn sie etwas sehen
wo sie ein komisches Bauchgefühl haben
wo sie das Gefühl haben das stimmt was
nicht auch wenn sie sich irren das ist
ganz egal ihn wird nie jemand ein
Vorwurf machen wählen Sie die 110 gucken
Sie sich an was da weiter passiert
bringen sich nicht selber in Gefahr aber
gucken sie was los ist helfen sie
unterstützen Sie und im schlimmsten Fall
greifen sie auch ein wir sehen das immer
wieder dass es Fälle gibt wo Menschen
eben eingreifen und das schlimmste
sozusagen verhindern es gibt auch Fälle
wo die Leute einfach nur zugucken und
dann kommen Menschen zu Tode ich bin der
Meinung man sollte immer wenn man das
Gefühl hat das stimmt was nicht sofort
die Polizei rufen und zwar nicht
übertrieben nicht übersensibel reagieren
aber wir haben alle glaube ich ein gutes
Bauchgefühl ein gutes Gespür dafür
stimmt da was oder stimmt da was nicht
das ist natürlich im Privaten
Lebensumfeld manchmal ganz schwierig
wenn es Nachbarn sind wenn es bekannte
sind wenn es Mitschüler sind der Kinder
vielleicht wo man blaue Flecken entdeckt
oder ähnliches aber ich finde in Zeiten
wo wir wissen was für schlimme Dinge
passieren auch gerade mit Kindern sollte
man immer lieber etwas zu früh reagieren
als zu spät und ich glaube wirklich
keiner möchte sich irgendwann die
Vorwürfe machen und Denken hätte ich
doch mal besser die Polizei gerufen dann
wäre das zu verhindern gewesen ich kann
da eben nur raten wenn sich an die
Polizei und die hilft Ihnen
[Musik]
manchmal hat man Opfer und Täter hat
Spuren und Zeugen Tatwerkzeuge und ein
klares Bild vom Ablauf und dennoch ist
es schwer diese Verbrechen zu ahnen und
ich Schuldigen zu bestrafen dann ist es
an den unabhängigen Richterinnen und
Richtern zu entscheiden Frank Schneider
erinnert sich unter anderem an diesem
Fall ich bin ein rechtskräftig
verurteilter Mörder so formal korrekt
weil die halt der Auffassung waren dass
irgendeiner und am besten ich
eingesperrt werden soll für den Markt an
meiner Tante am 15 Mai 2006 wird in
München die als Parkhaus Millionärin
bezeichnete Charlotte Böhringer mit 24
Hammerschlägen in ihrer Wohnung ermordet
der Verdacht der Ermittlungsbehörden
fällt auf den Neffen der Ermordeten 94
Tage dauerte Indizienprozess im
Anschluss wird Benedikt Tod wegen Modus
verurteilt aber es gibt keine
stichhaltigen Beweise für seine Tat und
betäubt Benedikt Benze tot seine
Unschuld naja es gibt immer wieder die
sogenannten Indizienprozesse also wenn
der wenn der Täter nicht gesteht obwohl
man auch da sagen muss wir hatten sogar
schon Fälle nach dem Täter gestanden
weil sie den Druck irgendwann nicht mehr
gewachsen weil die wollten nur noch ihre
Ruhe haben haben Tat zugegeben die sie
gar nicht begangen haben oder auch
manchmal aus Geltungsdrang also es gibt
ja manchmal Dinge die kann man sich gar
nicht vorstellen aber es ist so dass es
auch in Deutschland zum Glück sehr sehr
sehr selten aber immer wieder auch
fehlurteile gibt die sich hinterher
bewahrheiten und das die verurteilten
Täter in der gar nicht die Täter waren
und das natürlich noch Horror
Vorstellung dass Menschen unschuldig im
Gefängnis sitzen man kann sich das
selber gar nicht vorstellen du weißt du
warst es nicht aber du landest hinter
getan und deswegen gibt es immer
sicherlich wieder Fälle wo das sehr
fragwürdig ist ich möchte auch nicht in
der Haut von Richtern stecken die dann
entscheiden müssen anhand von Indizien
der Angeklagte bestreitet die Indizien
sprechen gegen ihn und dann ist es
manchmal sehr sehr schwierig hier auch
in diesem Parkhaus Mord war es ja eben
auch so er hat dort in dieser Wohnung
verkehrt er war mit dem Spurenleger der
berechtigt war dort sich dort zu bewegen
und deswegen ist es ganz ganz schwierig
für die Richter gewesen ich bin
felsenfest davon überzeugt die
entscheiden nach gutem Gewissen und die
würden jemand verurteilen wo Sie das
Gefühl haben er war es nicht die sind
sich sicher aber ob nicht auch da auf
anhand von Indizien manchmal Täuschungen
entstehen können Fehler entstehen können
mag man eben schwer beurteilen auf der
anderen Seite muss man aber sagen wenn
so ein Urteil gefallen ist ist es
unglaublich schwierig eine
Wiederaufnahme zu erlangen und das ist
von großen Hürden belegt deswegen ist es
eben manchmal auch so wie bei dem
Silvester Doppelmord in Iserlohn ist es
war klar einer der beiden hat geschossen
aber eben nicht wer und dann sind die
eben frei zu sprechen so schwierig das
auch zu ertragen ist viele die unseren
Podcast gut kennen erinnern sich
bestimmt auch noch an die Schrecken des
horrorhauses in Höxter der Fall geht
doch erfahrenen reporterkolleginnen und
Kollegen von Frank Schneider an die
Nieren
[Musik]
eine gewisse Angelika Wagner hat mit
ihrem schrottreifen Opel Corsa eine
Panne
eigenartigerweise ruft sie einen
notärztlichen Dienst an es geht aber
nicht um sie denn es befindet sich eine
nicht ansprechbare weitere Frau auf der
Rückbank diese Frau weist schwerste
Kopfverletzungen auf und die
Körpertemperatur beträgt nur noch 28
Grad zwei Stunden später verstirbt die
Frau im Klinikum Northeim und der
Polizei fällt eine Killerin in die Hände
aufgrund dessen wurden von der Polizei
Northeim im Zusammenhang mit der Polizei
zur ersten Ermittlung geführt man kann
dann relativ schnell auf ein Ehepaar auf
6 auszubauen will führt und Angelika W
dann trugen die Kollegen aus Höxter
Inhalte der kriminalakte vor und dann
hat es einer Verurteilung 1989 gegeben
wegen will von See grundlage waren
massive Quälereien einer Lebensgefährtin
von ihm
fast drei Jahren verbüßt und wenn man
das dann mal übereinander legt weil die
Todesumstände der beschädigten und diese
Vorstrafen dann kommt man gar nichts von
geschlossen erster möglicherweise
tatsächlich noch mehr hinter stecken
könnte bei der Untersuchung des
Schwerverletzten und späteren Leiche
werden schwerste Misshandlungen
fesselmale und eine Kopfverletzung
festgestellt diese hatte zwar eine
Hirnblutung und letztendlich dann zum
Tod geführt und war ohne Zweifel durch
äußere Gewalt entstanden
das angeklagte Pärchen geht vor Gericht
später aufeinander los die Sache wird
kompliziert absolut also wenn sich die
Tatverdächtigen gegenseitig beschuldigen
hier in dem anderen sagt der war es doch
da ist es unglaublich schwierig weil man
muss ja nachweisen wer was es gibt
natürlich Dinge gemeinschaftlichen Mord
da muss man nicht genau die
Tatbeteiligung klären sondern hat man
das gemeinschaftlich geplant und
durchgeführt aber das ist häufig erstmal
ein Trick den Anwälte ihren ähm
Mandanten auch sozusagen an die Hand
geben können für den Prozess aber hier
im Fall Höxter ist es zum Beispiel so
ich glaube die sind beide wirklich der
Meinung der andere ist mehr Schuld und
es gab schon immer solche toxischen
Beziehungen will ich die mal nennen die
sich gegenseitig befeuert haben für
solche schrecklichen Taten und dann ist
es natürlich immer sehr sehr schwierig
für Richter herauszufinden also es gibt
manchmal einfach Dinge die kann man sich
so gar nicht vorstellen und ich glaube
dass das ganz ganz schwierig ist häufig
für Gerichte dann wirklich zu
entscheiden wer war es jetzt aber da
muss man natürlich auch sagen da ist
natürlich die Arbeit der Ermittler
unglaublich wichtig weil dann muss man
die Aussagen
auch gerade in den Verhören ganz klar
noch mal den vorhalten sie vielleicht
auch mal in die Falle locken und man
muss die objektiven Beweise die man am
Tatort sichert die Spuren und ähnliches
oder auch Zeugenaussagen versuchen
übereinander zu legen und denen auch
noch mal vorzuhalten und sie auch ein
bisschen gegeneinander auszuspielen das
klappt häufig manchmal eben auch nicht
als Chefreporter ist sich Frank
Schneider seine Verantwortung bewusst
was es bedeutet über Verbrechen zu
berichten dabei die Opfer zu schützen
und sogar manchmal auch die mutmaßlichen
Täter und ich glaube auch dass Täter die
sich jemand anvertrauen dass auch tun
weil sie eigentlich selber damit auch
nicht leben können denn ich glaube zum
Mörder geboren ist der ist kaum einer
ähm es gibt Menschen die sind
abgrundtief böse und das erfährt man
auch manchmal ein Prozessen die
unglaublich eiskalt sind und und denen
das total egal ist was sie da anrichten
aber in der Regel glaube ich schon dass
viele Menschen auch irgendwann mit dem
hadern und auch unter den Eindrücken und
was passiert ist auch Leiden das läuft
in jede Nacht über die Bettdecke und
irgendwann vertrauen sich dann jemanden
an und wenn der dann zur Polizei geht
hilft am meistens auch demjenigen der
die Tat begangen hat denn das habe ich
schon häufig vor Gericht erlebte dann
sagt ich bin froh dass es endlich vorbei
ist das endlich ich sozusagen auch hier
sagen kann was passiert ist und dann
auch froh sind dass sie endlich nicht
mehr mit diesen Schuldgefühlen so leben
müssen
[Musik]
so auch im Fall des zerstückelten
Rockers Keim vom Anfang dieser Episode
das heute ein Teil der Beschuldigten auf
der Anklagebank sitzt ist den Aussagen
eines Kronzeugen zu verdanken der nicht
mit seiner Schuld leben konnte und hier
war es wirklich einer der auspackt dass
zum Beispiel auch ein ganz
entscheidender Punkt hier ist natürlich
der berühmte kronsorger ein aus dem
Milieu aus dem Rockermilieu der sagt er
kann mit dieser Schuld ich leben er
packt aus er hat immer gesagt ich musste
immer dran denken wie muss ich die
Mutter des ermordeten fühlen sie kann
ihren Sohn nicht beerdigen wie würde
meine Mutter damit umgehen wie würde
meine Mutter darunter leiden das war für
ihn die Triebfeder irgendwann zu sagen
auch wenn ich mich selber in
Lebensgefahr dadurch begebe ich ich kann
nicht mehr ich muss Auspacken häufig ist
es aber auch so dass Täter sich manchmal
Leuten anvertrauen mit ihren Taten
manche denken der will sich nur wichtig
tun oder denken ja der hat mir das jetzt
ein Vertrauen erzählt ich darf darüber
nichts sagen aber in der Regel ist es so
dass irgendwann mistvista zum Glück auch
sagen ich kann damit auch nicht leben
ich ich gebe das jetzt weiter ist damit
der Fall gelöst
das Journalisten Urgestein streicht sich
über die kurzen grauen Haare und
schüttelt den Kopf ja der Fall der
stückelrocker ist im Endeffekt noch ein
zwar nicht endgültig aufgeklärt es gibt
noch kein rechtskräftiges Urteil zwei
der Täter sind auch noch auf der Flucht
weil sie sich ins Ausland abgesetzt
haben aber es ist wenigstens jetzt zum
Prozess gekommen es gibt eine Anklage es
gibt jetzt einen Kronzeugen der eine
ganz klare Aussage macht und deswegen
weiß man jetzt endlich was passiert ist
man hat die fehlenden leichten Teile
gefunden man hat den Kopf gefunden und
man hat jetzt eine Vorstellung was
passiert sein könnte muss man immer noch
sagen noch gibt's kein rechtskräftiges
Urteil aber die Anklage gibt's die
sitzen in U-Haft sie sitzen vor Gericht
wie es im Fall km weitergeht wird die
nahe Zukunft zeigen
Chefreporter Frank Schneider bleibt für
Bild jedenfalls dran
[Musik]
ich bedanke mich bei Frank Schneider für
diese persönlichen Eindrücke aus einer
langjährigen Arbeit die übrigens viele
der spannenden Episoden dieser
podcastreihe möglich gemacht haben gerne
doch und ich bedanke mich bei Euch allen
da draußen wo auch immer ihr uns zuhört
euer Sky Demo
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland ist eine Produktion
aus den Wake world Studios
Projektleitung Simone terbrack
Produktion Fabian Scheffler Drehbuch
Lutz Neumann Redaktion Bild Frank
Schneider und Stefan Netzeband